WELL THE- TEXAS THING ON. THANK
WITH THE MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
THE FOR COMMITTEE PLEASE COME TO
ROOM ELEVEN HUNDRED SO THAT WE
CAN GET STARTED.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FOR TODAY'S HEARING IS
TAKING PLACE IN ROOM ELEVEN
HUNDRED. WILL BE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THIS HEARING BOTH AND HEARING
ROOM AND ON THE PHONE. THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND SHOULD BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING THIS HEARING
ONLINE PHONE NUMBER IS TOLL
FREE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE EIGHT
FIVE ZERO ONE ONE ZERO ZERO. IF
YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
NINE. AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL
ASSIST YOU. YES IT'S FUN CHECK
CHECK CHECK CHECK IT'S ON.
THAT'S WHAT I ASKED HER. CHECK
CHECK ONE TWO ONE TWO. THAT'S AB
CHECK AB ONE TWO THREE NOW. NOW. THANK THEY COME IN THE COMMAND
AREA ONCE A CAN YOU ALL HEAR ME
OUT THERE. CHECK YES I COME.
THAT WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY WITH
THAT. THIS IS IN THE WORK
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY. THE VOICE
OF GOD- I'M SORRY CAN YOU CAN
YOU HEAR CAN YOU HEAR ME OVER.
ON THE SCREEN OKAY. OKAY WE'LL
TRY TO FIGURE THIS OUT IN A
MOMENT. A MOMENT PLEASE.
OKAY FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE
TUNING IN ONLINE AND WATCHING
HEARING WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
TECH ISSUES WITHIN THE ROOM SO
WE- MICROPHONE. TEST TEST. S. S.
S.
TEST TEST. CHECK CHECK HELLO
OKAY HELLO CHECK CHECK OKAY.
ONLY BECAUSE THE SPANISH DJ AT A
CAN SENATE ON. WELL KNOWN THOSE
SWINDLES OKAY WE'LL START AGAIN
. AND RURAL TODAY WILL START
AGAIN GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME
TO OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FOR TODAY'S HEARING IS
TAKING PLACE IN ROOM ELEVEN
HUNDRED Y'ALL CAN HEAR ME OUT
THERE RIGHT. WE'RE GOOD OKAY. WE
WILL BE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THE END OF THIS HEARING BOTH
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE THE PHONE NUMBER IS TO
CONNECT THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT IS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND SHOULD BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING
THIS HEARING ONLINE. THE PHONE
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE
EIGHT FIVE ZERO ONE ONE ZERO
ZERO. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO. BUDGETS OF
FOUR AT A. S. M. DOT CA DODGY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KOREA HERE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NAZARIAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS.
THANK YOU WE WILL BEGIN ON THE
VOTE ON THE CALENDAR WE HAVE
TWENTY ITEMS FOR CONSIDERATION
WHICH ARE LISTED ON THE AGENDA
FOR YOUR REFERENCE WE WILL HAVE
THREE MOTIONS FOR THE VOTE ON
THE CALENDAR THE FIRST MOTION IS
ON THE FOLLOWING VOTE ONLY
ISSUES TOO AND SEVEN NINE
THROUGH TWELVE FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN. EIGHTEEN THROUGH TWENTY
- OKAY THE CHAIR RECOMMENDS
ADOPTING THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION SAID THANK YOU
FOR THE MOTION AND THE SECOND
LET'S HAVE THE ROLL CALL. AREA I
CAREER I COOPER. COOPER HI FONG
. NAZARIAN SIX WEEKS I. THANK
YOU THE SECOND MOTION IS ON THE
FOLLOWING VOTE ON THE ISSUES FOR
THREE SIX EIGHT AND THIRTEEN THE
CHAIR RECOMMENDS ADOPTING THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS CAN I GET
A MOTION. IN THE SECOND THANK
YOU ROLL CALL PLEASE AREA I HI
COOPER COOPER AYE FONG. NAZARIAN
WICKS WICKS I. THE FINAL MOTION
IS ON VOTE ON THE ISSUES ONE
THREE SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
RECOMMENDS ADOPTING THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS GOING TO GET A
MOTION. SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE
AREA I THREE I COOPER. COOPER
AYE FONG. IS THERE AN WICKS
WEBSITE. THANK YOU WE ARE MOVING
TO THE ITEMS TO BE HEARD IN ARE
GOING TO TAKE THEM OUT OF ORDER
TO ACCOMMODATE SOME SPEAKERS SO
WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER FOR A TAX PAYMENT
FLEXIBILITY FOR LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME TRADE. OR LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME. LET'S BEGIN.
AND WHEN YOU GET TO THE- THE
DESK AND MICROPHONES PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOUR MIKE BUTTON IS ON. I'M GOOD AFTERNOON I CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS NICK THOMAS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. OF
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMICS A
NEGATIVE ECONOMIC EFFECTS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED LOW
AND MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THEREFORE THIS PROPOSAL
PROVIDES- FLEXIBILITY TO THOSE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS WHO MAY BE
STRUGGLING FINANCIALLY BY
ALLOWING THEM TO DELAY THEIR TAX
PAYMENTS AND NOT INCUR INTEREST
OR PENALTIES RELATED TO LATE
FILING AND PAYMENT. IT WOULD BE
OPERABLE FOR TAX YEARS TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- BECAUSE
PAYMENT DUE DATES RELATED TO
THOSE YEARS WERE AFTER THE ONSET
OF THE PANDEMIC. I'M
SPECIFICALLY SINGLE TAXPAYERS
EARNING LESS THAN SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND MARRIED
FILING JOINTLY HOUSEHOLDS.
EARNING LESS THAN A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WOULD
HAVE UNTIL SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH I
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO PAY THEIR
TAXES. ARE FOR THOSE TAXES.
INTEREST AND PENALTIES RELATED-
WOULD BEGIN TO ACCRUE A NEW AS
OF OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. ON ANY UNPAID BALANCE
LASTLY IN SITUATIONS WHERE AN
ELIGIBLE TAXPAYER HAS ALREADY
MADE A LATE PAYMENT. I'M OR
THOSE ELIGIBLE TAXPAYERS AND
PAID A LATE PAYMENT ON. A LATE
PENALTY OR INTEREST- THE FTV
WILL AUTOMATICALLY REFUND. OF
THE PENALTY AND INTEREST
PAYMENTS. WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU LOL
. BRING YOUR WITH THE L. A. WE
HAVE NO ISSUES ON THE TRAILER
BILL. THANK YOU MUCH APPRECIATED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS THIS A
COUPLE ON ON MY END- THIS
PROGRAM BENEFITS THE GOOD ACTORS
IN THE BACK ACTORS AS THEIR-
GENUINELY. IMPACTED BY COAL
BETTER THOSE WHO FAIL TO PAY.
THEIR TAXES ON TIME. THE- OF THE
PROPOSAL SETS LIMITS FOR BASED
ON ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME AND
THAT WAS BASED ON TARGETING
THOSE TAXPAYERS THAT WE KNOW
WE'RE CLOSER TO THE MIKE PLACE.
THAT WAS- TO A FAST START OVER
I'M SO THE PROPOSAL SETS. LIMITS
ON ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME I'M
BASED ON TAXPAYERS THAT WE KNOW
WERE DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
BY THE EFFECTS OF THE PANDEMIC.
I AM AND THAT'S IN ORDER TO MAKE
THIS AS STREAMLINED AS POSSIBLE
AND AS TAXPAYER FRIENDLY AS
POSSIBLE. YES HI. I DIDN'T HAVE
MY GYNECOLOGIST DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE AN IDEA HOW
MANY PEOPLE COULD POTENTIALLY
QUALIFY. FOR THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD ESTIMATES THAT ABOUT ONE
MILLION I CANNOT TO BE ELIGIBLE
IN EACH TAX YEAR. THERE WOULD BE
SOME OVERLAP- FROM YEAR TO YEAR
. OKAY AND THEN JUST THE FINAL
FOLLOW UP IT WAS THERE A
SIGNIFICANT UPTICK DURING THE
CODED. AS TWO YEARS VERSES THAT
THREE YEARS. THE THREE TAX YEARS
PRECEDING IT. OUT WE'RE NOT
AWARE OF AN UPTICK BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT. DATA IS
PARTICULARLY EASY TO COME BY.
THANK YOU. WE ARE GOING TO HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN AND MOVE ON THANK
YOU GENTLEMEN MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO. THE DIRECTOR OF
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION.
THESE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
AND IDENTIFY YOURSELF MAKE SURE
MICROPHONES ON THANK YOU. BRIAN
RUTLEDGE DEPARTMENT OF- I
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT I'M
FORMER FINANCE I ALMOST SAID
FINANCE. MY APOLOGIES OF THIS IS
A TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT WHERE
THERE'S AN EXISTING POSITION IN
GOVERNMENT CODE FOR THE
STATEWIDE DIRECTOR OF IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION WE'RE JUST MAKING
CLARIFYING CHANGES HERE TO ALIGN
WHAT THE ROLE CURRENTLY IS DOING
AND TO MAKE THAT CLEAR AND
STATUTES. WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. AND WEBER BARBARA FINE
IT'S NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY ISSUES ON THE
LANGUAGE SPECIFICALLY ON THE
DIRECTOR ALTHOUGH WE DO WE JUST
REITERATED CONCERN YOU RAISED
PREVIOUSLY ON THE BROADER
PROPOSAL WITHIN GOBIZ. IF YOU
PUT CREATE A KIND OF IMMIGRANT
FOCUSED POSITION WITHIN GO
VISIBLE COORDINATE WITH THE
DIRECTOR- WE REMAIN UNCLEAR ON
WHAT NEW SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES
THAT POSITION WOULD BE
UNDERTAKING THAT ARE NOT
ALREADY. COVERED BY THE
DEPARTMENTS MANY PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE BUSINESS ASSISTANCE AND
SO WE THOUGHT WE MIGHT HAVE SEEN
SOME OF THAT DETAIL IN THIS IN
THIS TRAILER BILL OR FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION AND- THAT REMAINS
UNCLEAR TO US. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. CHECK CHECK THANK YOU FOR
THAT I THINK- I HAVE VERY
SIMILAR QUESTIONS AND WONDERING
IF YOU CAN PLEASE EXPAND. WHAT
IT WHAT DO YOU SEE AS A
DIRECTOR'S ROLE MOVING FORWARD
AND WHY SPECIFICALLY UNDERGO
THIS. SO I ALL JUST A BACK UP
FOR ONE SECOND BECAUSE I THINK
IT'LL HELP CLARIFY THAT. GOBIZ
CURRENTLY HAS A TWO PROPOSALS
RELATED TO IMMIGRANT AGGRESSION
WE HAVE THIS TRAILER BILL HERE.
AND THERE'S AN EXISTING POSITION
BASED ON STATUTE THAT'S WITHIN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. SO THIS
STATEWIDE DIRECTOR OF AN
IMMIGRANT IMMIGRATION- WHAT ARE
IMMIGRATION INTEGRATION
APOLOGIES. WOULD NOT MOVE FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SO THE
ROLE WOULD STAY THERE. ARE
THERE'S A SECOND PROPOSAL THAT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE ALLEY- IS.
IS MENTIONING WERE PROPOSING-
SOME FUNDING FOR A GRANT
PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE LOCAL.
GOVERNMENTS WITH THE- WITH
SUPPORT TO DEVELOP IMMIGRANT
SUPPORT SERVICES AND SO THAT'S
ACTUALLY A FORTHCOMING WITH MAY
REVISE WHAT WE'LL SEE MORE
DETAILS THERE. ARE THAT INCLUDED
AS PART OF THAT PROPOSAL A NEW
POSITION AGO BUSINESS I THINK
THERE IS SOME CONFUSION. OTHER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE JUST TO
CLARIFY IS AN EXISTING POSITION
AT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WHEREAS
THE GRANT PROPOSAL COMES WITHOUT
A POSITION AT GOMEZ. CAN YOU
HELP US UNDERSTAND- I'M TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND THIS IS A ONE
POSITION WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. WHERE IS THE YES-
CURRENTLY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
IS HOME TO THE STATE WIDE IT'S
IN STATUTE THE TITLE IS
STATEWIDE DIRECTOR OF IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION. SO WE'RE NOT GOING
TO CHANGE THE TITLE OR THE
LOCATION WE'RE JUST CLARIFYING
THE ROLE. THE ROLE WILL
ESSENTIALLY BE BROADLY THE SAME
WE'RE JUST ARE SIGNALING FOR
EXAMPLE THAT SOCIAL INCLUSION
AND ECONOMIC INCLUSION IS GONNA
BE. A FOCUS THAT'S ALREADY A
FOCUS OF THE DIRECTOR'S ROLE BUT
THE STATUTORY CHANGES JUST HELP
CLARIFY THAT. THANK YOU. THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE WE
ARE GOING TO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE FOR THANK
YOU. SWITCHES ONE MOMENT.
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD WITH ISSUE
NUMBER THREE AGAIN THANK YOU
GERMAN TO THE LAST PANEL THIS IS
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ATTAINABILITY FUND TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
IS BEGIN. I'M GONNA NAIL THIS
TIME BRIAN RUTLEDGE BUDGET
OFFICER GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. SO THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU FOR LETTING US UPDATE
YOU ON THE TRAILER BILL FOR THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BUDGET
SUSTAINABILITY FUND. JUST STEP
BACK RESTATE OUR GOAL HERE.
WE'RE TRYING TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN HIGH POVERTY AND
HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT AREAS. TO
TRANSITION TO A MORE EQUITABLE
AND MORE SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY.
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSITION WHERE
WE'RE MOVING TOWARDS A CARBON
NEUTRAL. ECONOMY IS CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES AND CHALLENGES
ACROSS THE STATE. FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WE'RE GOING TO TRY
TO HELP THEM WHEN THEY IDENTIFY
SOME CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES AND WHEN THEY
DON'T HAVE SUFFICIENT REVENUE
CAPACITY TO DO A SPECIFIC
PROJECTS THESE FUNDS WOULD HELP
THEM. DIVERSIFY THE ECONOMY AND
HELP CREATE MULTIPLIER EFFECTS-
THAT WOULD BE. VERY BENEFICIAL
NOT JUST TO THE LOCAL ECONOMY
BUT TO THE STATE. THE OVERALL
BIG PICTURE IS THIS HELPS US
MOVE TOWARDS. CARBON NEUTRAL I
ECONOMY WHICH- I OVER TIME IF WE
DO THIS SO. WE'RE A. WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT YOU CAN- WE LOOK
FOR TO GETTING YOUR INPUT
QUESTIONS. AS PART OF FINANCE.
AND WEBER TERMINA FINANCE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS. WELL THAT'S
WHEN THIS ITEM IS HEARD BEFORE
WE RAISED A FEW ISSUES WITH THE
PROPOSAL- FIRST WAS HOW IT WOULD
RELATE TO A RECENTLY ENACTED AND
STILL BEING DEVELOPED- RELATED
INITIATIVES THAT WOULD PROMOTE
LOCAL CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND
ECONOMIC DIVERSIFICATION- AND WE
ALSO NOTED THAT- THE PROPOSAL
THE PARAMETERS ON THE PROGRAM
MORE QUITE BROAD AND VAGUE AND
IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO DETERMINE EXACTLY
WHAT OBJECTIVES AND WHAT THEY
WOULD BE GETTING FROM ALLOCATING
FUNDING TO THIS PROGRAMME. OF
THE TRAILER BILL IS PUT SOME
ADDITIONAL PARAMETERS ON THE
PROGRAM BUT IN OUR VIEW THE
LANGUAGE IS STILL A VERY BROAD-
IT STILL PROVIDES A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF DISCRETIN TO GOBIZ TO
THAT THE CRITERIA FOR THE
GRANTS- DETERMINE WHO WOULD GET
THEM WHAT THEY WOULD BEFORE- AND
SO GIVEN THOSE FACTORS AND THIS
PROPOSAL DOESN'T ALLOCATE
FUNDING INTEL TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR DOESN'T ALLOCATE ANY
MONEY IN THE BUDGET YEAR ARE WE
THINK IT COULD BE WARRANTED FOR
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO DELAY ANY
KIND OF APPROVAL ON THIS PROGRAM
AS THE ADMINISTRATION TO COME
BACK WITH. MORE OF CONCRETE
OBJECTIVES AND PROJECTS HERE
THAT OF THE LEGISLATURE COULD BE
CLEAR ON WHAT THEY WOULD BE
GETTING FOR FUNDING FOR THIS
INITIATIVE. THANK YOU SO JUST TO
BE CLEAR THIS PROGRAM WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED UNTIL YOU'RE TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. THAT'S
CORRECT TO THE REQUEST IS FOR
ONE MILLION OR ONE HUNDRED
MILLION BEGINNING IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR ONE TIME
ANOTHER HUNDRED MILLION IN
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. AND
THEN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
IN TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX. BUT
THE PROPOSAL HERE FOR THE
TRAILER BILL IS TO ENACT THIS-
AS WRITTEN TO GET THE PROGRAM ON
THE BOOKS HERE. AND WHAT
FEEDBACK HAS THE ADMINISTRATION
RECEIVED FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES THAT MAY BE ELIGIBLE
FOR OR THE FUNDS. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION SO WE'VE IDENTIFIED
AS WRITTEN THE TRAILER BILL
WOULD MAKE TEN COUNTIES
ELIGIBLE. AND OF THOSE TEN WE'VE
SPOKEN AT THIS POINT TO ABOUT
FOUR FIVE. ONE OF THE BIG
REQUESTS FROM COUNTIES HAS BEEN
TO MAKE A TO MAKE THIS A DIRECT
REVENUE REPLACEMENT PROGRAM.
THAT IS NOT A THE INTENT HERE-
WE'RE WE ARE TRYING TO HELP MOVE
TOWARDS A BIGGER. A BIGGER
PICTURE VISION WHERE WE'RE NOT
JUST SAYING YOU KNOW YOU'RE
LOSING X. Y. Z. DOLLARS ON SOME
EXISTING SERVICE AND WE'RE GONNA
BACK FILL YOU. IN FACT THIS IS
DESIGNED TO HELP OUR MOVE
TOWARDS PLANNING FOR ABOUT
TRANSITION WHERE YOU HAVE A MORE
DIVERSE ECONOMY. YOU HAVE A MORE
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY AND SO THIS
IS NOT DESIGNED TO BE- THE
DIRECT REVENUE REPLACEMENT
HOWEVER. IT VERY MUCH RESPONSE
TO IF YOU ARE MAXED OUT YOU
DON'T HAVE THE REVENUE TO PURSUE
A PROJECT. THAT MIGHT BE
BENEFICIAL THAT MIGHT PROMOTE
SUSTAINABILITY OR DIVERSIFYING
YOUR LOCAL INDUSTRIES THIS IS
WHERE THIS WOULD COME IN SO IT
IS- WE'RE TRYING TO RESPOND TO.
SOME REVENUE LIMITS THAT LOCALS
MIGHT HAVE. WHAT IS THE FIRM
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IF YOU'RE
TRYING TO DIVERSIFY A LOCAL
INITIATIVE. WHAT WOULD BE THE- I
GUESS THE IMPACT OR
ACCOUNTABILITY OF SUCCESS ON
WHICH PROJECTS GET SELECTED.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION SO AS
- AS SPECIFIED IN IN THE TRAILER
BILL WITH PROPOSED IT DOES SAY
THAT GO BIZ CAN DETERMINE THE
CRITERIA. WE'VE TRIED TO FILTER
IT OUT AT A AT A PRETTY HIGH
LEVEL AND LEAVE A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY HERE. I'LL SAY THAT
THE NUMBER ONE REASON WE'RE
TRYING TO BE FLEXIBLE AND NOT
PREDETERMINED WITH. WITH A. B.
C. AND D. REQUIREMENTS UP FRONT
IS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO MEET THE
LOCALS WHERE THEY ARE. SO EACH
OF THE COUNTIES IS GOING TO BE
IN A DIFFERENT SPOT IN TERMS OF
WHAT THEY'RE EXISTING INDUSTRY
INFRASTRUCTURE MIGHT BE- WHERE
THEY MIGHT NEED TO GO ARE ONCE
AGO AND SO. FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE REASON
THAT WE DRAFTED THIS WAY WE
WOULD MAKE CLEAR THAT WE ARE
OPEN TO INPUT. ON THE
LEGISLATURE WHERE WE'RE HOPING
TO MAKE THIS SUCCESSFUL SO WE
LOOK FORWARD ANYTHING- THAT
MIGHT BE HELPFUL. MY ONLY
CONCERN AROUND THAT WOULD BE
JUST THE BROAD DISCRETION FOR
GOBIZ CAN CREATE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN WHICH- PROPOSALS
AREN'T LOOKED EQUALLY OR
DEPENDING ON WHO IS MAKING THE
PROPOSAL- HOW OLD. GO BIZ IS. I
GUESS HOW GOBIZ WOULD EVENTUALLY
JUST DECIDE. WHICH ONE SMALL
FORWARD AND WITH WHICH COUNTY. I
TAKE THAT AND IF ALL NOTED OUR
BIGGEST A FILTER THAT EXISTS IN
THE TRAILER BILL AND SPECIFYING
ELIGIBILITY IS THAT A IT COUNTY
IS ONLY ELIGIBLE IF IT'S IN A
HIGH POVERTY OR HIGH EMPLOYMENT
AREA. SO THAT BASICALLY LIMITS
IT DOWN TO AT THIS POINT TEN
COUNTIES SO FROM ARGUE THAT IS A
BIG MITIGATING AGAINST THE
CONCERN YOU'RE RAISING BUT WE DO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT. AND WHAT
HAPPENED FINAL QUESTIONS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THE STABLE OF A
CIVILIZATION FUNDS ARE GONE. I
WILL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BE ABLE
TO. CONTINUE OR FUNCTION AT THAT
POINT. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THAT SO THE- THE IDEA
IS THAT. THROUGH THE ENTIRE
PROCESS- FROM. WORKING TOWARDS
APPLYING APPLYING AND THEN.
PURSUING A PROJECT THAT'S GRANT
FUNDED HERE WE WOULD BE THINK
VERY CLOSE ATTENTION WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH THE COUNTIES-
SO WE DO ANTICIPATE WHEN YOU'RE
APPLYING AND WHEN WE'RE WORKING
OUT OF THIS IS A FINAL PROJECT
THAT- HAVING A PLANT THAT'S
REASONABLE AND FEASIBLE TO
ACHIEVE SUSTAINABILITY- AFTER
THE FUNDING. FALLS OFF WOULD BE
A CRITICAL PART. THANK YOU FOR
THAT IF THEREARE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD TO THE NEXT ISSUE
AND HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN THANK
YOU GENTLEMEN. I WE ARE GOING TO
GO BACK TO ISSUE NUMBER ONE. THE
FISCAL SPRING FISCAL.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS MERRIAM BARCELONA
ENGINEER- AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE FINANCIAL INFORMATION
SYSTEM FOR CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HEARING US TODAY IN
OUR SPRING FINANCE- LETTERS.
TODAY F. THIS CALLOUS ASKING FOR
THIRTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FUNDING. FIFTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING.
AND SIXTY FOR PERMANENT
POSITIONS ACROSS THREE SPECIFIC-
REQUESTS. THE FIRST IS FOR
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AND
SECURITY AND INTERNAL CONTROLS
AND COMPLIANCE UNIT. AND THE
FISCAL SYSTEM IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST FINANCIAL SYSTEMS- IN IN
THE WORLD. AND IS CONSIDERED
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND SO
THERE'S SOME DOES JUST ADD
ADDITIONAL BELTS AND SUSPENDERS
TO OUR SYSTEM TO MAKE SURE IT IS
A SECURE. I'M SYSTEM THAT SECOND
SPRING WATER- TRANSITIONS
CONSULTANT WORKLOAD. I HAD TO
STATE STAFF AND STARTS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE WORKLOAD
WORKLOAD BACKLOG THAT WE HAVE-
ACCRUED OVER THE YEARS OF
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT. AND THE
THIRD AND FINAL SPRING FINANCE
LETTER IS TO ON BOARD- TWO OF
THE TEN DEFERRED DEPARTMENTS-
AND START THE ON BOARDING OF THE
THIRD ONE TO START THOSE
CONVERSATIONS- AS THE COMMITTEE
MAY RECALL THERE WERE TEN
DEFERRED DEPARTMENTS. THAT HAD
MODERN ERP ACCOUNTING SYSTEMS IN
PLACE WHEN WE WERE DEPLOYING THE
FISCAL SYSTEM AND THEY WERE
DEFERRED UNTIL THE END OF THE
USEFUL LIFE OF THOSE SYSTEMS AND
SO THERE'S A LAPSE PROPOSAL DOES
INCLUDE ON BOARDING OF. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TO BE
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND STARTING THE WORK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION. CALTRANS AND
THEN IN THAT LAST B. C. P. WE
ARE ALSO ASKING FOR. SOME SOME
ADDITIONAL CONTRACTED RESOURCES
TO ASSIST US IN WORKING WITH
BOTH THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE AND TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES
AND THE DEPLOYMENT OF THEIR-
THAT HUMAN CAP THAT CS PS THE
PAYROLL SYSTEM. AND THE HR
MODERNIZATION EFFORTS AND THEY
ARE WORKING WITH AGAIN THE I ONE
OF THE LARGEST EXPENDITURE ITEMS
THAT WOULD NEED TO BE CAPTURED
IS CURRENTLY CAPTURED IN OUR-
ACCOUNTING SYSTEM OF COURSE IS
PAYROLL- SO THAT WILL BE. THOSE
ACCOUNTING TRANSACTIONS NEED TO
TRANSITION. I'M I THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF IN THE L. A. O. FOR THEIR
ON GOING WORK WITH US OVER THE
YEARS. IT HAS BEEN QUITE A
JOURNEY TO GET FISCAL TO WHERE
IT IS TODAY LAST YEAR WE DID
THREE POINT FIVE TRILLION
DOLLARS A BANKING TRANSACTIONS
IN OUR SYSTEM. IN NEARLY A HALF
A TRILLION DOLLARS IN ACCOUNTING
TRANSACTIONS THROUGH THE FISCAL
SYSTEM. SO IT IS A- QUITE A
QUITE A FEAT THAT WE HAVEN'T
ACHIEVED ALLEN WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH WITH-
BOTH LIKE I SAID DOOR STAFF AS
WELL AS- THE L. A. O. TO ADDRESS
THE ADDITIONAL CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED. AND HOW TO
MOVE US ULTIMATELY TO ON THAT
BOOK OF RECORD AND TO AND STATE
AND MAKING SURE. THAT THE SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE DEPLOYED. IS
MAINTAINS TO THE CURRENT LEVEL
STAYS MODERN- AND SECURE. SO
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT THEY MAY HAVE. THANK YOU A DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I BELIEVE A IS WROTE.
BERMAN OF FINANCES NOTHING
FURTHER TO ADD AT THIS TIME. L.
A. L. BRIAN MINSKER LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OUR ANALYSIS OF
FISCAL SPRING FINANCE LETTERS
ARE INCLUDED IN TODAY'S AGENDA
SO WE'LL TRY TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS BRIEF- IT IS OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
THIS. OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
MONTHS STARTING IN EARNEST LATER
THIS MONTH. THESE DISCUSSIONS
WILL BE TWO IMPORTANT DECISIONS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
THEIR AFTER SUCH AS IF AND WHEN
FISCAL WILL BECOME THE STATE'S
BOOK OF RECORD. SO THESE
DECISIONS MADE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION MUST BE CLEARLY
COMMUNICATED TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO INFORMANTS DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
FUTURE BUDGET ACTIONS AND POLICY
DIRECTION. WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPT SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORT LANGUAGE TO MAKE SURE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE ARE CLEAR ON WHAT
WORK REMAINS TO BE DONE WHAT
DISAGREEMENTS BETWEEN PROJECT
PARTNERS MUST BE ADDRESSED. AND
WHAT DECISIONS MUST BE MADE TO
FINISH THE PROJECT AS
ENVISIONED. TO ENSURE THIS
REPORT IS DELIVERED TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY A CERTAIN DATE
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO ADOPT
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WITHHOLD SOME AMOUNT OF
FUNDING FOR USER REQUESTED
SYSTEM ENHANCEMENTS. UNTIL THE
REPORT IS SUBMITTED. ALSO WE
HAVE REVIEWED THE STAFF COMMENTS
IN THE AGENDA ON POSSIBLE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO RESPOND
TO SPECIFIC CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PROJECT INCLUDING SOME RAISED IN
OUR ANALYSIS. AND THE
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
TO INCREASE FUNDING FOR FISCO TO
BEGIN ONBOARDING ADDITIONAL
DEPARTMENTS IF POSSIBLE. AT A
HIGH LEVEL THE ELEMENTS PROPOSED
TO BE INCLUDED IN THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE HAVE MERIT BUT
WHAT ARE MORE QUESTIONS BUT-
ASIAN AND THE LEGISLATURE. ARE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE
RECOMMENDATION IS INTENDED TO
MAKE SURE THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE BOTH UNDERSTAND THE
DECISIONS AND WORKLOAD THAT
REMAIN. IN COULD INFORM FUTURE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
DISCUSSIONS. SIMILARLY WE HAVE
NOT SEEN THE PROPOSED
PROVISIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
BUT I UNDERSTAND THE MERITS OF
POSSIBLE FUNDING TO ON BOARD
ADDITIONAL DEPARTMENT SOONER.
WHERE THE SUB COMMITTEE TO AGREE
WITH THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO
ADOPT PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IN THE PROPOSED
PROVISIONAL BALLOT BILL LANGUAGE
WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE ON. BUDGET TRAILER
BILLS. THANK YOU FOR THAT ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. OKAY
SEEING NONE WE HEARD ABOUT THIS
ISSUE ON MARCH FIRST WHEN WE
DISCUSS THE DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AUDIT ON THE FISCAL
SYSTEM STAFF CRAFTED THIS
RECOMMENDATION TO RESPOND TO THE
LACK OF CERTAINTY AROUND. CASH
FUNCTIONS OF THE CONTROLLER THE
GOAL OF THE TRAILER BILL IS TO
HAVE CLEAR DEADLINES FOR THESE
REMAINING ROJECT ACTIVITIES. SO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE CAN HOLD THE
PROJECT ACCOUNTABLE TO REALISTIC
AND DEFINED OUTCOME MEASUREMENTS
GOING FORWARD. THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO ADOPT THE
SPRING FISCAL LETTERS THE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE AND PLACEHOLDER
TRIP A TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. DO
I HAVE A MOTION FOR THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION. ALL RIGHT
EXCELLENT THANK YOU WELCOME
PLACE. AREA I HI COOPER COOPER
II FONG. IS THERE IN WICKS WIXII. AND NAZARIAN HIGH. THANK YOU-
THE FOR THANK YOU THAT CONCLUDES
OUR LAST. LAST AND ALL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE ARE GOING TO GO
BACK TO- MEMBERS JOINING THE
COMMITTEE FOR A VOTE ON THE
CALENDAR. FIRST MOTION IS TO
ADOPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR VOTE ONLY ISSUES TWO SEVEN.
NINE THREE TWELVE FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN AND EIGHTEEN THROUGH
TWENTY FONG. IS THERE ANY IS
THERE IN I. SECOND MOTION IS TO
ADOPT THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR VOTE ONLY ISSUES. FOUR THREE
SIX EIGHT AND THIRTEEN FONG. IS
THERE IN THIS AREA HI. THIRD
MOTION IS TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR VOTE ONLY
ISSUES. ONE THREE SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN FONG. IS THERE IN
THERE IN HIGH. THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT WHICH
WE ARE ACCEPTING IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND OVER THE PHONE THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT TO THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE
ALSO LISTED ON THE SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING THE PHONE NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS ONE EIGHT
FIVE ZERO ONE ONE ZERO ZERO IS
THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT THE
ROOM. MANAGER MEMBERS ALEX
TORRES WAS STRATEGIES THREE
SIXTY ARE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL INDEPENDENT
VIDEO ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA ONE
OF THE ITEMS THAT WASN'T ON THE
AGENDA BUT WE WANTED TO RAISE TO
THIS COMMITTEE'S ATTENTION. IS
THE POTENTIAL TOP ADOPTION OF
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TWEAKING
THE ELIGIBILITY GUIDELINES FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA VENUES
GRANT PROGRAM THERE ARE A LOT OF
APPLICANTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
THE LIMBO SITUATION. UNABLE FOR
THE STATE'S VENDOR L'INDUSTRIE
TO PROCESS THEIR APPLICATION
JUST BECAUSE OF SOME INADVERTENT
BEARS IN THE ENABLING LANGUAGE.
I WANT TO THANK DIRECTOR GRAY
WITH CALLAS BUT HER TEAM WHO
HAVE BEEN. EXCEPTIONALLY
RECEPTIVE TO THE PROPOSED
CHANGES I JUST WANT TO RAISE
THIS FOR THE COMMITTEE'S
CONSIDERATION WE UNDERSTAND
WORKING THROUGH THE PROCESS WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
DIRECTOR REYES OFFICE BUT- LOT
OF VENUES IN A BID OF ANY USE
AND- BEST OR PROMOTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THAT HAVE
YET TO RECEIVE BADLY CRITICALLY
NEEDED AID- BECAUSE OF THIS THIS
PROGRAM BUT- HOPEFUL TO GET
THOSE CHANGES ADOPTED IN THE
BUDGET. THANK YOU. CNO
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT- IN
THE ROOM WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO I COMMAND AGAIN ONE.
TEN ZERO AND FIRST WE WILL HEAR
FROM LINE NUMBER NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
THINK IS PAUL YOUR ON BEHALF OF
THE KERN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS APPRECIATED.
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED- KERN
IS ONE OF THE COUNTIES THAT HAS
BEEN TALKING TO THE
ADMINISTRATION. THESE ARE
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS OF THE
CHAIR HAD THESE ARE JUST HIGH
POVERTY AND HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT
COUNTIES. THIS STATE WOULD HAVE
A TO THE COUNTIES IN THE
UNINCORPORATED AREA WHERE LARGE
SCALE SOLAR AND WIND. AND A LOT
OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT THE
STATE WANTS AND NEEDS- TO
ACHIEVE ITS ITS ALTERNATIVE
ENERGY GOALS IT'S IT IS
LITERALLY WHERE THESE PROJECTS
ARE GOING. SO PROPER STAFFING
FOR THE PLANNING DEPARTMENT AND
- THE COUNTIES. OVERALL ABILITY
TO DO THESE THINGS THAT IN SOME
CASES IN JUST GIVE ME ANOTHER
MINUTE MEDICARE IN SOME CASES
ACTUALLY. COST THE COUNTY'S
MONEY. FOR THEM TO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT IT HELPS THE
STATE ACHIEVE ITS GOALS IS VERY
IMPORTANT EXAMPLE AND LOSING
MONEY IS LARGE SCALE SOLAR IN
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY ENJOYS A
PROPERTY TAX EXLUSION THAT
EXCLUSION IS CURRENTLY COSTING
KERN COUNTY TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. SO KERN IS
LOSING THAT MUCH MONEY ANNUALLY
TO GENERATE THE POWER THAT IS
GOING TO THE URBAN AREAS AND
AGAIN HELPING THE STATE ACHIEVE
ITS GOALS ON APRIL THIRTIETH THE
STATE ACTUALLY PRODUCED ENOUGH
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY TO MEET ITS
DEMANDS STATEWIDE. AND KERN IS
VERY PRESS ROLE THAT IT PLAYED
IN DOING SO. BUT IT'S SUFFERING
FINANCIALLY AS A RESULT AS ARE
SOME OF THE OTHER COUNTIES AND
SO- WE WOULD URGE YOU TO MOVE
THIS ALONG. AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME AND- GRATEFUL TO THE
ADMINISTRATION LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH THE MORE THANK YOU
. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE NUMBER TWELVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NOW F. BOTTOM ALL WITH
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND MY
COMMENT ON ISSUE TOO IT'S JUST A
CLARIFICATION THAT IT IS AN
EXISTING POSITION WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THAT THERE
IS A NEW POSITION- DIRECTOR THE
IMMIGRANT INTO- THAT WILL BE
FORTHCOMING IN THE MAIN REVISED
THAT WAS IDENTIFIED. IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THAT THAT
WOULD BE. TO POSITION TO ONE
WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
OTHER ONE IS IN KOBE IS. EARLY
FOUNDATION LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE NEW POSITION AS IT. IS
REVEALED IN THE MAIN REVISED
WITH ADDITIONAL- COMMENDATION.
AND ADVOCATE COLDER CLUB TO BE
INVOLVED IN THAT. SO IS IT
REGARDS THE ITEM NUMBER READ
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE THING ONLY
FIND TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. AND
PREACHING KERN COUNTY COMMENT.
AS EARLY FOUNDATION WORKS WITH.
ORGANIZATIONS IN KERN COUNTY- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING HOW IT.
FURTHER DEVELOPS IN REGARDS TO
HOW WE INTEGRATE- OUR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT THEY
COLDER'S AND THAT THEY ARE
INTEGRAL IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE ECONOMIC- ISSUES AND WORK IN
JOBS IN THE LOCAL COMMUNITY YOU
CAN BETTER TEN COUNTY THOUGH. AS
A RECOMMENDATION THAT THAT WOULD
CONNECT THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WITH RESIDENTS AND
THE COUNTY TO FURTHER ADVANCE
ECONOMIC STABILITY- IN USE THAT
IDENTIFY COMMITTEE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
COMMITMENT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. WELL LINE ELEVEN
. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON TOP OF
THE COUNTY OF HUMBOLDT CALARE
AND MERCED IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER THREE YOU THINK ANY
MANIFESTATION FOR A PROPOSED IN
MATH AND LOOK FORWARD TO ARE
YOUR COMMITTEE BRINGING THAT
CONCLUSION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PINE SIXTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ELENA
SANTA MARIA WITH NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA JUST CALLING ON
BEHALF OF- ITEMS RELATED TO NEW
HR POSITION OR- POSITIONS WITHIN
OFFICES THAT ARE CREATING- NEW
OFFICES THAT WE JUST HOPE THAT
AN ADVOCATE FOR THAT THESE
OFFICES AND POSITIONS ARE
CREATED WITH THE A LINE THROUGH
RACIAL EQUITY GIVEN HOW EQUITY
IS IMPORTANT- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE HOW WE'RE DOING THAT IN A
HOLISTIC MANNER AND JUST WANT
THE FLAG FOR THE- TO MAKE SURE
THAT ANY NEW POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS ARE BEING THOUGHT
THROUGH AND THOUGHT WITH- THE
RACIAL EQUITY LAND. A TIME AND
LOOK FORWARD TO YOU- WORKING
MORE ON THESE ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATOR WE- THE SHUTTING
DOWN PUBLIC COMMONALITY NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS IN THE ROOM
THANK YOU TO OUR BUDGET STAFF
AND EVERYONE THAT PARTICIPATED
IN TODAY'S BUDGET HEARING WE ARE
NOW ADJOURNED.